[Music]
shortly after going on a budget her
she was at first on board with you know
trying to take control of our money and
then it started to take a turn where she
said that she didn't want to have
anybody telling her what to do with her
money you making this phone call is an
act of bravery and so i applaud you
[Music]
what's up this is john with the dr john
delony show
so glad that you're with us
talk about mental health relationships
schools whatever's going on in your life
the madness the good stuff whatever's
going on do you want to be on the show
1-844-693-3291 it's 1-844-693-3291
love to have you on
and walk alongside you with whatever is
going on in your life
and rolling up my sleeves here man
if you don't get the sleeve roll right
it's just kind of dumb
i don't know dude i'm
i'm a fashionista i'm pretty incredible
then we should do a segment on how to
roll your sleeves up i have a lot of
opinions
um hey if you uh don't want to call go
to johndalonny.com ask that's
a-s-k-johndaloni.comask
and
like we talked about last show i'm
excited to announce five new editions
questions for humans cards coming out
soon here's a sneak peek at some of the
new decks we've got multiple decks
coming out over the next several months
um some for very specific groups like
educators
um and other places but the five that
we're announcing right now
workplace edition
so this is like i just started a new job
or i'm a new boss i'm a new leader or
we're at a retreat and now we're all
staring at each other or we have
leadership
luncheons or whatever and we
i don't like you guys i don't even know
how to talk to you guys
now i've given you an entry point
and it is very very low five very simple
and no apps and you can tell everybody
put your phones away
workplace edition we have dating
editions so we had the we have the cards
that the best selling cards by far are
the relationship ones right people are
married they've been dating for a long
long time and we're gonna swan dive into
this thing deeper and i've had couples
that are married for 20 years that
circle back like i did not know the
stuff about my spouse and we laughed we
cried so these are
dating these are hey we're fresh off the
internet so let's meet in person and now
you find yourself over coffee or your
first dinner
or your third dinner and you're like uh
what do we do now we have talked about
all our bands that we like and all the
dumb stuff that happened to us in middle
school and why i don't like my dad and
why your mom is weird and now we're
stuck and so these cards are for people
who are just getting into relationship
and dating and there's a girls night out
and the guys night out and i i said last
time i was not a fan of these like
number one i got no business writing a
deck of cards for girls night out
because i've never been on one of those
and i don't know what happens on one of
those um so we got some incredible women
here um in the office to help alongside
that um and to create some cards and it
wasn't just a bunch of dudes in a room
that would have been ridiculous um and
you guys kept asking for it hey we want
cards for girls night and so
ta-da we got you and then we got the
guys night cards out and by the way
they're not broad out yeah bro
these cards are for everybody so whether
y'all are playing dungeons and dragons
or whether you're on a camping trip or
hunting trip or whether you are
like on
uh you're doing your weekend deployment
for your once a month um check in with
your uh
you know with national guard you can use
these anywhere for any group it's gonna
be great and then there's the parents
and teens edition
for some reason teenagers just change
languages and they change smells and
they change everything else and these
cards are designed specifically for
parents and teens to begin to
communicate with one another in a little
bit different way you can use them when
you're driving for the breakfast i want
you all to take with your kids all them
so workplace edition dating edition
girls night out guys night out parents
and teens
go to johndaloni.com
humans you can pick them all up and
they're going to come in a bundle to
pack also um that i'm excited about so
go pick them up
begin transforming your family tree put
the screens down and start connecting so
excited all right let's go to the phones
go to david in fresno california what's
up david how we doing
uh not as good as i deserve dr john but
i thank you for taking call time to talk
to me you got it man so let's get into
it brother what's up how can the help
uh so nima
together and one from previous marriage
uh hold on one second um i just you cut
out on me so back up and do that one
over again
yeah uh so me and my wife have been
married for three years now um
we have two kids one together and one
for one from her previous relationship
and recently we've been hitting a point
where she seems to be disconnecting from
me um a couple months ago we hit the
point that i felt was financial ruin and
the first time in my adult life of 15
years
uh was late making payments for the
house for rent and
i felt like everything was crushing
around me
i discovered dave ramsey and the ramsey
network and we discussed about going on
a budget
shortly after going on a budget her
she was at first on board with you know
trying to take control of our money
and then it started to take a turn where
she said that she didn't want to um
have anybody telling her what to do with
her money
and then recently on sunday we were
having a conversation where
she
she told me that
because of my desire to
open and expand our communication
that i'm pushing her away
and i'm at a point where i don't i'm not
sure what to do
how long have you all been together man
uh four years four years
well i i know this much haven't been
married for a lot longer than that you
making this phone call is an act of
bravery and so i applaud you it's hard
um good for you man
often when somebody
when couples
have these moments these breakthrough
moments actually let me back up what
happened financially what pushed you
over the over the cliff
um
so she had start she was unemployed for
the last year after my daughter was born
okay um was she unemployed or was she
being a stay-at-home mom
being a stay-at-home mom she started to
do some small businesses because
we were just skimming by on my income
okay
here's the deal
the language we use truly matters deeply
in some of these situations okay
and so there's a difference between
saying
she was just sitting around unemployed
and
she we chose for her to stay at home for
a year with our newborn
and some little in a mix of both does
that make sense one of those has some
vitriol in it it's got some character
assassination to it one of them is
we agreed mutually we're gonna scrape
and claw our way by because we think
this is more important in this season
does that make sense
yeah
maybe all weren't that intentional about
it
i wasn't as intentional about it okay
it was kind of a
decision that she made and i was told to
that
this is what i'm going to do because i
think that i think that it's best
and from my perspective
i didn't
there was looking at the numbers and the
math of it
it was
it was going to be a strong burden and
trying to maintain
the level of life that uh we were both
wanting to live
did you bring in this new life did you
sit down and have that conversation
yes
i'm looking at the numbers and i'm
scared about what's the next year is
going to hold for us
i did okay um
at first it looked like it could be
possible but then i sat down we were
looking at the numbers for the next year
and i said
you know with the added expenses of
diapers clothes that are going to be
coming every two weeks because the
baby's not going to stop growing
i don't see how we're going to be able
to make this work
and at that point she said well then
i'll start making baby clothes i'll
start making
bows
and she started that business of hers
online
but she didn't
she didn't put um
she wasn't committed to it
it was a
i'll make it when i feel like it i'm not
going to go out and really try to
sell these bows and then but i'm just
going to continue to buy the fabric to
make the clothes that i want to make for
my child so you end up losing money on a
side hustle
yes yeah
um
what is whenever i hear couples
say they can't get on the same page or
somebody calls them in your situation by
the way your situation is very very
common okay
often
there's a back story in the back story
usually not always usually is something
like
a woman marries a guy who's a schemer
he's always got a plan if we just do
this then we can get here and if we
can't do that then we're going to do
this i'm going to buy this car i'm going
to flip it for this
there's always a thing going
so then when things get scary we're
broke
like you are as a husband and i've been
there by the way where you're pacing
around at night when your wife and kid
are asleep and you have your hands on
your knees because you can't breathe and
you're like i don't know how we're gonna
do this
i've been there that's a scary feeling
am i right
yeah
so then you get on youtube and you find
ramsey solutions which i happen i work
here because i happen to believe it's
the best program that exists for walking
people through how to deal with your
money
um
as a path to freedom
and
then the next morning she wakes up
you're all excited you tell her all
about i got this plan here's what we're
gonna do and your excitement wins the
day for for a few weeks until it the
reality of it wears off
and it's less about the plan and it's
less about unification and it's more
about how it was pitched and
the it's just a steady it's just another
scheme and a long line of schemes
and so
putting her aside like i want to set her
over for a second because at the end of
the day the only thing on planet earth
you can control is you and that you can
deal with do you have anger issues do
you have frustration issues i hear in
your voice resentment i hear in your
voice
like you're done and i don't know what
to do or i hear you in your voice giving
up and it might be financially it might
just be you're exhausted it might be
you're done with the marriage i don't
know where you are but i can feel it on
you tell me where you are
i'm i'm getting to the point of burnout
okay
between working full-time
i i was able to get to a point where i
got into a job and pursuing a career
that i love and i'm super passionate
about
and i got excited because i finally went
from
working in a job for a job and instead
of working in a
uh
a vacation as a vocation okay
and what's that job what are you doing
uh so i work in a recruitment team okay
um i do entry level recruitment
specifying in veterans and people with
disabilities love it awesome and that's
that's good work all that's that serves
everybody right that's fantastic and are
you good at it
yeah um i came on i came on the team
quickly got recognized on a
national level with the company
for my endeavors in the
in the recruitment and
the outreach that we do
creating
community engagement across the entire
nation between the company and
veteran organizations so
but you have another side to you
what is it
it feels that
i feel
that
i have to handle everything
why who told you to deal with everything
it's it's the actions um i
i come home from work i pick up my
daughter go home from work
and
i i have to is your daughter daycare
uh she stays with family
what does your wife do during the day
she works as a bank teller so she is
working now
yeah she got a job a few months ago
she's working as a bank teller okay um
she
so she gets home
shortly after i do if not maybe just a
little bit before but because of where
she works i pick up my daughter okay um
it's
more
cost effective because it's on the way
home for me rather than her driving out
of her way absolutely and those are i've
got i've got memories of picking up my
son and taking my son to school taking
my daughter's school that are that are
great memories
um
take me
here man you and i could unpack this for
a long time
i wanna
two things i know for sure one i'm not
getting the full picture here okay i'm
not calling you dishonest there's
something else here that's big
the second thing is it sounds like
one of two things is happening
either when i say something i'm not
getting the full picture
either there's something that you have
done or that makes you
untrustworthy or
a way you respond or you get angry or
you shut down there's something here
that is contributing to the wedge
and i don't know what it is and we can
that's a whole other phone call okay but
i want you to be honest with yourself
about what you bring to this
the second part of this
is
it sounds like two people trying to do
life the way they want it to be done
and without sitting down and mapping out
saying hey who are we going to be
together
and not about money yet not about how
we're going to raise kids yet not about
our
what are we doing like what are we
building together
because we're we're now we're now joined
we're forever in relationship even if we
got divorced tomorrow we are forever in
a relationship because we have a child
together
and so who do we want to be what do we
want to become what we want to do
and that's a different conversation that
hey i think i can get us out of debt
because one of those is a scheme the
other one is let's change everything
and getting out of debt is a path to
freedom and peace in our home
that both of you may not have ever known
i don't know your childhoods
and then when you have that conversation
and somebody says i'm out i don't want
to do that
i don't want to dream with you i don't
want to be on the same page parenting
like i'm going to raise my kid how i
want to raise my kid
um i don't want you telling me what to
do with my money i don't care about that
then we're going to look at things like
are there mental health issues are there
um does this person just not want to be
married to you and that's a hard reality
to face but we got to face it otherwise
everyone just gets miserable we have to
deal with that
um you see where i'm going i'm headed
here
it seems like there are some broad
deep
um
or i'll just tell you in my house we
have a money conversation every two
weeks or so but for sure 100 every month
when we get paid
we have a calendar
conversation once a week what does this
week look like what do you need from me
this week how can i honor you this week
um
it's going to be deposit week so i'm
going to be busier at work it's going to
be not deposit week this is recruiting
week this is the the end of the month so
we got to get our numbers up
like it's it's being a part of one
another's flow of life
and if somebody opts out of that i do
not want to participate in life with you
now we're going to have big hard
conversations about is this marriage
viable
does that make sense
yeah no it does um
have you heard about have you had those
what i hear often is people think
they've had that conversation and they
have not
not to that level okay
it's been more of like a
breeze over
and like okay what are we gonna do this
week well we've got a b c and d going
okay well i can take care of this you
can take care of that but
not in the depth of there you go how can
i help support you well and when you
what you just said is beautiful because
that's what's happened to relationships
all across the country especially during
the pandemic
which is couples became great
co-managers of a household
they are not a married couple with
intimacy and connection striving to
create something beautiful in the world
and change family trees
you get the difference there hey i got
this task you get kid i'll get this you
pick up dude on the way home we'll
collapse on the couch watch an episode
will you do bedtime i'll get this i'll
do the diaper and then we repeat
that's a life of co-management it's a
life of misery and at some point one of
you all will go looking for connections
somewhere else if not both of you
and it sounds like you guys met
you i've been dating for four years
i mean i mean y'all you've known her for
four years you then you got married
relatively quick right and you had a kid
yep okay
and then you got into the pandemic and
then you all had some major money issues
and so there's been one crisis after
another after another and it's hard to
get your footing back when you're out to
sea and you just can't seem to touch and
you're swimming as hard as you can and
you get one toe down in the water i mean
on the ground and then you're you're off
back out to sea again
what i would love for you to spend a few
minutes a couple hours
writing down what you need
not what you're trying to solve not what
you're trying to fix
like dude my name is david and here's
what i need
i miss i miss
i miss my wife
i want to breathe when it comes to money
i want to not worry about money i want
to be good at my job i want to be a
great dad i want to co-parent together
really well
um
and then i want you to take your wife
out to breakfast and say hey we're going
to spend a couple hours and we've got
married quick we've shot out of a cannon
quick you're struggling with things
um
you tell
your desire to be open with her makes
her more uncomfortable for some reason
why do you think that is by the way
she have no health issues or are you can
you be loud and and kind of this is my
way
no we both can be loud and this is my
way
she
she has been diagnosed with severe
depression
after she was diagnosed um i knew that i
needed help so i sought a counselor and
i've been seeing a counselor for the
past few months because
i'm living with somebody that is not
okay and i need to know how to manage my
feelings in it awesome good for you man
that's fantastic
have you noticed some things working
with a counselor that you need to change
a lot of a lot of what the counselor and
i have been working on is understanding
the functions of the behaviors in our
house not only mine but hers and the
kids
and then once i can start understanding
the function of the behaviors i can
start addressing my reaction
okay you keep doing what your counselor
says but i'm gonna add to that
i want you all to sit down together
would y'all go to breakfast and i want
you to do
[Music]
ask each other are we still both in this
are you are you do you want to be
married to me and this is going to be a
risk-taking vulnerable conversation
because i want to be married to you
and i want to create a pretty amazing
life and depending on how she grew up
and depending on how you grew up you all
may have come from really combustible
homes
where relationships and intimacy and
vulnerability weren't safe weren't good
weren't okay and we're gonna have to
build something new that we've never
even seen before
but are you still in because i am
and from there
draw up on a piece of paper a couple of
columns what are your dreams about where
we're going to live what do you want to
do professionally or not do
professionally
what about when it comes to money let's
dream about a house like if you could
pick any house what would it look like
is it a ranch style house is it a 5 000
square foot like what does it look like
and then what we're gonna do is we're
going to commit together i want
we both want to see these things come to
fruition
what do we have to do and then goes back
to what your accounts are talking about
our behaviors what do we have to change
in our everyday life to make this stuff
happen
and now you are in it together and one
of those tools is
getting out of debt one of those tools
is healing your marriage in your
relationship so here's what i'm gonna do
for you man i'm gonna send you um stay
on the line
and jenna's gonna pick up i'm gonna give
you a year subscription to ramsey plus
all of the financial piece videos
all of the every dollar app
that i that all of us use around here
because it's the best on the market um
to help keep track of all your spending
but and it helps your wife can buy
something over here and i can buy some
over here and it all dumps into the same
app which is great
um i'm also gonna send you a copy of my
book on your past change your future
it's about saying okay here's what
happened and now what are we gonna do
next
so i'm gonna give you all a bunch of
tools but i want you to sit down and
have a true conversation with your wife
at a retreat not at home not in a fight
this is a beautiful planning opportunity
and a risk because she might say hey i
want out i do not want to be with you
and then you all have to deal with what
comes next after that but i don't think
she's there
start there and let's build something
new let's create a picture of where
we're going to live into and then we're
going to get the tools and i've given
you a bunch
um a couple hundred dollars for the
tools then we're gonna reverse engineer
this thing and we're gonna go make it
work day by day by day okay
give that a shot and
it may be time for marriage counseling
for both of you she's struggling mental
health you're struggling to love her in
new ways and different ways and to act
differently it may be good for both to
be able to go see somebody together all
right i'm proud of you david
check back in with me and let me know
i'm gonna walk alongside you on this one
we'll be right back
hey delona here it's that time of year
where a lot of us are traveling again i
mean i've been traveling everywhere
flying driving living out of hotels and
that's all fun and good for a while but
it can be exhausting and it can wreck
your sleep that's why there's nothing
like coming home to your own bed
especially when you've got a world-class
mattress like dream cloud dream cloud
mattresses will make a massive
difference in the quality of your sleep
which is an absolute game changer
especially when you've been running hard
right now dream cloud is offering their
biggest deal ever exclusively for our
listeners when you buy a mattress you
get 499 bucks and sleep accessories plus
an additional 250 off that's a total of
749 in accessories and savings listen if
you're not excited to come home to your
own bed it's time to make a change visit
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
deloney to get your new mattress today
that's
dreamcloudsleep.com promo code deloney
all right we're back let's go to mandy
in portland oregon what's up mandy
hey how are you dude i'm dancing on the
ceiling lionel richie style what's up
what are you doing fantastic um i'm
sitting in my car talking to you oh
sweet
i know right all good things happen when
you have to hide in the car to talk
what's up well yeah so the the topic of
discussion is getting ready for school
so i decided to head down the road and
have a conversation in peace um
a lot a bit of a back story here and
then kind of the core of of our question
um i have a 15 year old freshman it's
his first full year back to school since
covid
in 2020 we
took a break and homeschooled him so
he's back with friends which has been
good and bad
um notice the last few months that he's
having a lot of difficulty um
both kind of at home in school he's
generally a really mellow
easy-going kid having a hard time
keeping his grades up not participating
in class
started to find some communication with
friends on his phone that
a lot of drama just a lot of um
really kind of uh
hate to say this but it almost feels
like a competition amongst friends of
like who can
have the most drama in their life at any
given point in time and
um
there was some some stuff that was just
flat out not even honest or truthful so
we we called him out on that just some
stuff he was saying about his home life
that doesn't even
remotely happen
um we did see some
interesting conversations between him
and his best friend and his best friend
did say at a point you know hey are you
are you okay like you wouldn't think
about hurting yourself he's like well
i've
thought once or twice but i would never
do it this is something that seems
really outside of his character um but
we asked him about that of course
um so now you know it's uh a comment um
and then he did kind of go into
some stuff that i hadn't heard from him
before like uh he doesn't like how he
looks and he
he's really thin and tall he doesn't
like his body and he doesn't like this
and he doesn't like that um
which you know understandable teenagers
a little bit tough um but as we started
digging we just kept finding more and
more things like the stuff on his phone
that he knows he's not supposed to have
um
you know we keep calling him out on that
just struggling at home to do the
smallest things like
use soap in the shower like wash your
hair
yeah
just these things that i know
comes along with teenagers but
basically anytime we shut him down on
something he
he's now kind of resorted to going
behind our back and finding a new way to
do it so um
take away the phone and and the school
kind of has free-for-all on their ipads
so then he's sneaking the ipad to talk
to friends and
um doing things on the ipad and and
they're supposed to be locked down by
the school but they're they're really
not we found out
he's learned a lot at school during the
day and not getting his schoolwork done
we've reached out to teachers they don't
really seem to care a whole lot which is
interesting um
so for me it's uh
we we did have a blow up after i wrote
you and
he made the comment again about you know
i think about hurting myself um so at
that point i kind of put on the brakes
and said we're you know we're gonna
we're gonna look for a counselor
um
to kind of maybe help him process some
of this stuff because it's he and i
ninety percent of the time
step dad we've been married since he was
six together since he was three so he's
a constant figure but he's uh
works for the sheriff's office and is
gone a
dad lives close by um but they don't see
each other you know every week or so
but dad is
great about helping like if he's
grounded from something he'll be
consistent and follow through on it but
he's not proactive in in terms of like
we're gonna monitor how much he's on
games and we're gonna have some
boundaries and we're gonna have some you
know structure it's just more like hey
come on up and it's kind of a
free-for-all so i don't feel like
that's one more battle that i can't
really take on and control it's not
my home up there i spoke about what i
feel is
good for our son but i can't really
control that piece so that's right we're
together a lot and we're kind of about
battling all that but at the end of the
day i'm kind of just trying to navigate
through
knowing that he's going behind our back
and he's doing stuff he's setting up
like hidden gaming accounts he's
thinking his ipad in the middle of the
night he's kind of done all recon that
he could come up with some of it very
creative but um
we have some core values in our house
with honesty and trust and
we speak about those a lot and
it doesn't really matter what you do if
you're honest about it you know we'll
work through it so the problem is even
when we confront him he lies until
i find evidence and then
i know that he's done something so
we're trying to figure out how to
navigate through
picking our bottles between silly what
seems like silly things like
you know bathing properly and cleaning
up after yourself and picking up your
room and those things versus the things
that are really
kind of core value important throwing
him into
a accountable kind of resilient member
of society yeah
um we notice a lot of other parents
around us are really lacks and
don't seem to be tuned in so we battle
that a lot of oh my friend gets to do
this and my other friend gets to do this
then yes so here's um let me hop in here
um yeah
well
get to a core question for me because
there's a lot here we could talk about
yeah there's a lot there's a lot so yeah
picking my bottles picking our bottles
of what you know
because i feel like the last couple of
months i'm on him every day right like i
i don't even look for things and i and
they're there right and it's exhausting
and i know that he's exhausted and now
there's this anger and there's
resentment and
some days are fine but other days are
just fire and
so picking my battles on you know not
hammering them every day but then on
these bigger issues and the honesty and
the um
being transparent and being honest about
things when they do go down
where where has he been walking with him
where has he picked that up
you know i'm i'm not sure um
we've had instances before where he's
come clean on stuff and no no like it
does does you or his dad or a stepdad
exaggerate things get flustered about
things
uh
no okay so it's just all i'm not sure
i'm not sure at his dad's house i don't
think so his dad's pretty even tempered
i definitely grew up with that with
explosive parents and so that's a whole
nother part of this where i'm trying not
to be like them right so but sometimes
sometimes do i go the other way
in some and here's the thing when we're
nuclear reactors like i said in a
previous call like
when you're trying not to do a thing
our kids feel that
and so it ends up
the same
it's less right than smashing a counter
until like you know a cabinet until the
the door falls off
but if i'm sitting there raged out
staring at the floor because i'm so mad
i can't look at my kid i'm saying i'm
not gonna yell i'm not gonna yell i'm
not gonna hit the counter i'm not gonna
bang things they're still feeling this
nuclear reactor inside of me
and they find themselves
they find themselves responsible for the
emotional reactivity of the adults in
the room
and
so backing all the way out you
regardless of how long
step dad's been there there's gonna be
this toggle
okay
there's gonna be until it's addressed
with a counselor and it's addressed with
you and directly and this is a process
right this isn't just like a one
conversation over dinner kind of thing
um
he's going to as he gets older begin to
ask the question what was it about me
that that dad didn't like and why he
left
what was it about me what did i do to
contribute at that young of an age
how have i had to navigate this
relationship with this new stepdad and
it's kind of weird and it's all it's
going to be normal for him to pull away
from that and think that his real dad's
the greatest guy ever and then that will
switch completely and then you're the
bad guy and then she he's the there's
gonna be that natural
back and forth and the word that i love
that dr gabor mate uses to describe that
is just internal chaos inside of a kid
okay
and so when i'm trying to get to the
bottom of these type of things that
you're mentioning
the two words i'm gonna always go back
to are connection and chaos
where does this human being feel plugged
in to the point that he can drop his
shoulders and say here i am
and if
every interaction is did you soap oh my
gosh why how long are you in there what
are you doing in there you soap you know
you told me you don't like how you look
and look at your acne you go or whatever
is going on with the 15 year old right
right exactly yeah um
then
then what the the child knows i don't
get connection there i get lectured i
get combative interaction and i have to
have that relationship with my parents
and so i'm gonna keep coming back i'm
gonna keep coming back i'm gonna keep
coming back but i'm gonna go find
connections somewhere else
and if i can find connection with people
who all wear um
all white goth makeup and listen to slow
droning metal music cool i'll find
connection there if i find connection
with people who are oh yeah you know
what's going on in my house oh yeah
guess what's going on in my house
then i'm gonna find it there because
that's where the the i i'm able to ring
a bell will people where people will go
oh tell me more about that
because he doesn't get that at home he
gets pick up your room what are you
doing you know what i'm saying
and then when he looks around the
landscape it's somebody's missing
this guy's trying his best and i like
him but he's also if i like him then i'm
being disloyal to my dad and if i'm
disloyal to my you know i mean there's
just this toggle going on
and then man you hand somebody a screen
and there's just it's a giant pacifier
it's a it's a
it's it's a giant joint of the most
potent marijuana it just calms
everything out
and it's hard not to keep going back and
keep going back and keep going back
um i don't
here's how i'd parse this stuff out when
it comes to
i'll just tell you about conversations
i've had in my house is that cool
the conversations i've had in my house
my son's 12
is there's been a few seasons when i've
sat down and said i love you
and i've talked to you about you know
wearing your clothes
i'm gonna stop having that conversation
i'm gonna stop talking about your hair
cause here's what i know there's a
darwinian thing that happens he's gonna
have a friend that's like is that what
you're wearing and then that will put an
end to that right or he'll get with a
group of guys who all love that he wears
his clothes that way and
good for them right
i am gonna make a conscious decision i'm
out on that
if you want some help with
acne you're with a workout program the
thing
i am all in it for you i will walk
through hell with you
but i'm not going to i'm going to stop
pounding you yeah when it comes to
honesty you gotta be honest here
you gotta be honest here here's a great
bridge and you've probably heard me say
this if you listen to the show regularly
a great bridge to honesty with a kid
is a notebook that you and him share and
you say it's private and you put on his
bed and say here was how your day was
and all i want him to he has to respond
to it and put it back on your bed when
he's done he can write 15 paragraphs he
can write one sentence today was fine
and i'm not going to hound him for his
answers but i'm going to keep showing up
i'm going to keep showing up and this is
a five-month game a year game
but what you're doing is just giving him
a place where he can write it down and
be honest because right now interactions
he's learned are not safe
and i'm not saying you were wrong or out
of line for getting onto him about
using soap and bathing and put his
clothes away all those things are normal
they just begin to add up and add up and
add up
we will have i think it's a hundred
years
i think we've created a generational
curse by what happened with the two to
three years of kids being stuck okay i
do
and i'm not going to it's just an is
kind of like i got to deal with gas
prices right now and me losing my mind
about it and getting angry and raged out
and punching solves nothing about gas
prices so
i know that my kids are going to
struggle with connection for a long long
long time right and so i'm going to be
super
highly intentional in my house i went
and bought a foosball table and an air
hockey table they were cheap i got them
off the internets and they're
not going to survive my kid's childhood
but
my son said dad
friends don't want to come over here we
don't have any video games and so we
just we stare at each other and so okay
cool i'm going to give you all that too
and by the way hey to my wife we're
going to budget once a month we're going
to take the kids somewhere and do a
thing i'm going to start curating this
connection because they're not getting
it in the other place
and you and your and your husband have
to have some hard conversations if my
kid had unfettered access to the
internet via a school
um device i would raise bloody hell
about that i'm already not cool with the
chromebook stuff but i've been convinced
that there's enough supervision on those
to at least
block the majority of the stuff
well what we learned is at the
elementary and junior high level they're
really locked down we had no idea at the
high school level they'd do nothing he
can go on youtube he can do whatever he
wanted yeah um so i'm it's driving me
mad because i send him off to school
with this tool that they've given him
right and then they they call me and say
well your kid's not doing well in this
class because he's not participating and
i'm like well
right here's why i i would have
conversations um
like well then you got to come up with
an alternative assignment for my child
and we'll put him through the ard
process
um but he will not be on screens because
his screens contribute to the following
behaviors and um so if you have to go
some ada route i'm sure there's a path
you could take i don't know i'm shooting
it off the hip here but i'm going to
tell my school you've got to come up
with alternative assignments because you
all have not put in the pla in the
structures for this device these tools
you're handing these children
and i'm not going to give my kid
unfettered access to all the pornography
in the world and all the violence in the
world and all of the crazy conspiracy
nonsense and all of the fill in the
blank i'm not going to give them access
to all the distractions from the actual
learning that's going on
that takes place between a teacher and a
student
and so i need you all to come up with
some alternative things and your kid is
going to hate it
i know that
it's gonna feel weird and isolating and
whatever
[Music]
it's the same as saying hey when we were
kids you can't go to a party at that
kid's house because his parents don't
have supervision and then let you all
drink i'm not sending you over there and
oh mom y'all hate me
no i love you so much i'm gonna step in
the gap i'd rather you be mad at me
but that's gonna come back to some core
values one of my core values is it's my
job to do what i can to help you be safe
and to protect your mind and it protects
your body i can't protect you from
everything i had this conversation with
my 12 year old yesterday actually
you're entering into an age where i
can't keep you safe from everything
you're gonna have to make some choices
and there's gonna be consequences to
those choices and you will always always
always have a home to come home to
always
but i think it's important to split down
on a piece of paper and this is your
homework assignment write down the
things that you just hassle about
constantly hassle hassle hassle hassle
hassle
and then what are the core values what
are the challenges and then sit him down
and say hey i've screwed this up
i'm gonna quit hassling you
if you don't clean up your room that's
you just telling me that you don't wanna
play video games and that's fine you
don't have to
but if you want to play video games then
the choice you're going to make is that
you're going to treat my house with
dignity and respect
um i'm going to quit nagging you about
your clothes and your stuff
um
i'm just gonna stop and when you're
ready i'm all in i'll help you with the
soap stuff i'll help you with acne stuff
i will help you with the products i'll
help you with whatever y'all can do
financially
um
i really want him to have a purpose in
your home
right now he's purposeless he's aimless
and he's doing everything he can to
connect and so it's important for you to
look him in the eye over breakfast one
morning just the two of you or maybe you
and your hus your husband
or maybe all three your ex-husband your
husband
and look him in the eye and say hey you
matter to us this house doesn't work
without you
we love you
and you contribute you're a part of this
thing
because when he sees no purpose or a
bigger picture then he's gonna go find
one somewhere else so give him one give
him a role to play
and go back to those core values and say
we're not gonna budge on this i refuse
to budge on honesty i refuse to budge on
integrity on violence i'm not going to
um i'll but fudge on hair product
have big poofy hero for all i care
and then starts the accountability
process he's going to lean up against
those boundaries that you draw and say
he's going to hold are they still going
to love me an answer is going to be yes
but think connection
where can we get him connected to us to
each other to his friends
and then where can we
pull some of the strings on this chaos
and
but he's got to see a counselor you all
got to see a counselor because he's got
to heal from the chaos he's been living
in for a long time
and hopefully y'all can do this healing
together
thank you so so much for being brave
thank you for the call we'll be right
back
have you ever thought about how a lot of
us would drop anything to help somebody
else but we often don't give ourselves
the same level of care we spend time
energy money on everyone else but when
it comes to making time for vacation for
exercise for talking with a mentor for
sleep even going to therapy
we don't do it and we don't even realize
they won't even think about it
you are worth it
this month betterhelp online therapy
wants to remind you that you are
important
that you are worth being well and
therapy is a super important way you can
show up for yourself
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone even live chat
sessions with your therapist you don't
even have to see anyone on a camera if
you don't want to it's more affordable
than in-person therapy and you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours today dr john dolone show
listeners get 10 percent off their first
month so decide to invest in yourself
you are worth it and go to
betterhelp.com
deloney to get 10 off that's
betterhelp.com
deloney
all right we got one more let's go to
brooke in washington d.c what's up
brooke
hello thanks for taking my call thank
you for calling what's up
um
i'm asking for some advice on how to
move on from a future that i had planned
with an ex-fiancee
and the feeling of betrayal
and abandonment i have when i never
really got any closure from him
i'm sorry
it's okay did he up and flip the switch
on you and take off
um well kind of he was actually already
away because he was on military orders
um
so he just called me and told me all
this
that he
while he was gone he was away for like
two months and
during that time he called me and said
that um he no longer wanted children
which wasn't a huge deal for me
but he also said that he doesn't believe
in god anymore and
considers himself agnostic now
and that was a bigger deal to me
because my faith is important to me um
and so it just kind of came out of the
blue i was blindsided um
he left here in january
and told me all this beginning of march
and i haven't seen him since
when he called you did he end the
relationship
um well or he's like hey i still want to
get married i love you just we're not
having kids and i don't believe in god
right now
yeah that was kind of how it was he
um
did you break up with him is that why
he's the ex-fiance now
um i don't know i say he broke up with
me he would say he
that i broke up with him i think
um
basically i didn't want us to make like
a restaurant rash decision over the
phone um i asked him if he would like go
to counseling with me um when he got
back
and
but for whatever reason like over the
phone conversations and texting when we
weren't together just one thing kind of
led to another and um we
like i kind of
told him i wanted to postpone the
wedding um
and because i didn't think there was any
way we could like work through that
um and still get married we were
supposed to get married in july
um
and so
that's what i said he took that as like
i was breaking up with him because i
told him i would like he had some
furniture at his apartment that was mine
and i told him like hey i'll like get my
furniture out until we figure this out
because
i was moving i was like i need to move
to another apartment and um
take my stuff even though i didn't live
with him at the time so hey brooke i
just just met you like two minutes ago
and it sounds like you broke up with him
and and
you might regret it
you might know it was the right thing
for you and be devastated by it
but all healing starts with ownership
of what we do or what was done to us
yeah i guess like
yeah i did i kind of was the one that
ended it
um
because
i didn't see how we could like make it
work at the time before we even went to
counseling or anything yeah and hey you
don't have you don't have to explain
your boundaries to me they're your
boundaries
um one of your boundaries for being
married to somebody was i want to be a
mom
one of your boundaries for being married
to somebody is
i
want faith to be a central part of my
life and our relationship
and somebody you were with who had
previously committed to those things
changed
yeah and so they
banged their head up they put he put his
boundaries out
and suddenly you found yourselves in two
neighboring homes that were completely
walled off from one another
yeah right and so we have to ask
ourselves about our boundaries is are
these things fixed for me
or are
um it's gonna sound crazy uh i used to
be obsessed
i used to think the most attractive
thing in the world not the most but one
of the most top ten
was uh left-handed girls who write
left-handed i don't know why i have a
thing and i love girls who have lots of
tattoos it's just a thing i always have
since i was a kid
i married a teacher like an elementary
school teacher
a right-handed elementary school teacher
no tattoos
right
and in fact when my friends first met
her they were like are you serious like
what happened to you and i was like no
she's really great and they're like i
know she's great but it's that we had in
our head that you would bring home
and we had a lot of jokes that we can't
use now because you wrote him like a
teacher right
and so
i tell you that to tell you like i had a
boundary
my wife's gonna be like this
and then i met the woman who is my wife
and that i had to look at my boundaries
that i had drawn that were 19 years old
for they were idiotic and i had to
change them because they were dumb
and then there's other boundaries
that had she said hey i don't um
not only do not share your faith system
but i don't ever want it mentioned in my
house um our kids if we ever have kids
are not gonna have any sort of
connection to this
you can go do that on your own but we're
not doing that
that'd been a big deal for me
yeah um and i'll also tell you i've been
through
years
of my marriage where i've been agnostic
i think the whole thing's just stupid
the whole faith is just dumb
the whole thing is ridiculous
and i've had cycles of being really high
up on it all and real low up on it all
and now i've settled into a place where
i feel really great for like the last
five to ten years
um in what i believe and how i believe
it and it's very very different than
some of my coworkers it's it's different
than my wife but we have a com we have a
common respect for one another does that
make sense and so i don't necessarily
think that a guy who's on deployment
who makes a phone call
is suddenly cast himself into stone
it tells me that there's something
deeper in this relationship
yeah and my guess is you
you could pull something apart that
things weren't okay when he left at some
shape form or fashion is that true or
tell me i'm out to lunch you can say no
it was perfect until he left
um i mean i thought it was
i thought it was really good
um and when he went out there
he just kind of stopped um communicating
with me like he normally would
and
so like i kind of did push the issue i
was like what what's going on
um
and he told me like
he
he didn't want to tell me because if
i if he did he knew i would break up
with him
and so like i kind of
eventually he did obviously sure um
and my guess is there's more to that
story
yeah
my guess is there's more that either he
told you
or that he hasn't told you but you kind
of know
that's my guess maybe again he could be
sitting here and be like no dude it was
just those two things um i mean i i
didn't really know i knew he wasn't like
as strong in his space as i was but um
before he left he was like oh i can't
wait to like when we get back we'll like
look for church together because we both
had moved to a new state sure um
he's like we'll look for a church
together we'll find a place
um that we both like and
so is he is he on deployment is he on
deployment now or is he just in another
city
no he was just in another city for just
two months so is he back home now
yes okay
have you all gone out
just no he will not see me oh he won't
talk to you anymore okay is he
heartbroken or is he done
um
he we talked for a little while um
just like on the phone and texting
um but
he says that he can't do that anymore
because it's just
harder on him he never wanted to meet up
with me um
because he said he knew that if he saw
me he would just want to like
tell me basically what i wanted to hear
and
say he would
go to church with me and believe in god
for me and all these things and he's
like and that's not fair to you
um
and so i don't think he's really he
wasn't really done he was just like
it sounds like in a sideways way however
different i would have done it
it sounds like he was trying to honor
you
yeah and i mean that's what he said the
whole time he's like this is
me telling you all this was the selfless
thing i could do because i didn't want
you to marry me and then present me
there you go and again if i he was
sitting here i'd be like dude i would
have done this a different way but he
didn't call me and ask me and so i to
get back to your original question
you have a picture in your head of
july
and you have a picture of your head of
august and september
and you have a picture of your head of
little knuckleheads running around
and him coming home in his uniform and
then meeting him at the door
and you have pictures in your head of
him coming home surprising you and
snatching you away from some
grody commodity romantic weekend away
you've got pictures in your head of all
that stuff
and so when you
grieve the loss of somebody whether they
pass away will they break up with you
but they leave you
you have to deal with all of these
pictures
you had plans with this dude
right yeah yeah
and it's
it's something you can't skip over you
can't run around it there's no hacks
you've got to grieve it
even to the point where you see
something funny you immediately pick up
your phone to text the meme to him
because that's the next place right or
when the someone knocks on the door you
instantly your body knows he's on the
other end of that door even though he's
not
right
yeah and i i felt like i've grieved it
i don't know i felt like i um
went through the whole grieving process
and then
i'm like
it just cycles back like i felt better
for a little bit and then
just something small will remind me of
him and i'm like back at the beginning
and like part of me was like
i really miss him and a lot of me still
just wants to be with him and just be
like it's okay i can accept that you
don't
believe what i believe and we can make
it work
um
but he didn't really seem
willing to do that either like
just like no that's not fair to you
um and that that honestly is what makes
me think there's bigger things to talk
about here
um and that's i mean there is but
i'm
right i'm confident there's more to this
story um and so
let me say this
just because you miss him doesn't mean
that being separated is the not the
right thing
and just because you hurt really really
bad and now you're questioning your own
boundaries doesn't mean that you weren't
right
and both people in a situation like this
is heartbreaking as it is both of you
can be right
and end up apart
you know what i mean
and
hollywood told us that's not how that's
supposed to go
you know
so
you mentioned something important that i
want to touch on
i think of the grief process as a spiral
and it loops back
and when it loops back and i miss him
i'm not gonna grab a drink i'm not gonna
immediately turn on netflix or pick up
my phone to start scrolling something
i'm gonna sit for five minutes
okay it's gonna sit i miss that dude
okay
this hurts i miss him
yes
and i feel like i've really
i don't know i also feel
like i hurt him
because
i mean he has dealt with
issues of abandonment before and he said
he felt like i abandoned him
um
and so you have some guilt there you
have some yeah and then he also said
like through this whole process um
he's just been pushed further away from
um
what his face what he had and or what
his faith was and and you got to be
careful because now he's projecting
himself onto you
he's making choices about those things
now
right
he's choosing to not see you and to not
have closure he's choosing to
um
to he chose to
dump a lot on you on the phone
and
he chose not to receive your returned
dump back on the phone right so there's
a comes a point when if he wants to walk
away from his faith even faster great
he's choosing that that's not something
you made him do
right if he chooses to not talk to you
because talking to you hurts so bad
that's hard to hear
and it's important to go
and i said it's a spiral so what happens
what i've seen happen over and over with
folks is it loops back and every time it
loops back if i'll sit in it for a
second
for five minutes for 10 minutes
the next time it loops back it's still
there but it hurts a little bit less and
it hurts a little bit less where i see
most people get hung up is they don't
want to let go
yeah
that's what i'm having trouble doing and
that means you haven't grieved it yet
right you've hurt you've been in pain
but grieving is the process of
acknowledging reality
this is the way this is
and then asking yourself that scary
terrifying question what do i do next
right and you've been connected to a guy
that's probably a pretty good guy and
he's definitely strong he's got all the
good character all the stuff but it's
been a
it's it's been an anchor point for you
and now it's a matter of
what's next
i wish there was an easy way i wish i
was like a biohack all that's just
nonsense there's one way through it um
one other thing i'll recommend to you
brooke is you have to have to have to
have other people with you while you're
grieving
grief demands a witness as the great
david kessler says you gotta have other
people with you so you gotta have
girlfriends that you hang out with that
you're honest with that you say hey i'm
just not doing okay today that you text
today's a low day
uh i miss him
or today's a great day let's go out
let's go do something fun
right or i don't feel like going out but
i'm gonna go anyway because i'm gonna
end up having a good time with these two
or three or five or six girlfriends
whatever but make sure you've got
friends that you're connecting with stay
on the line jenna's gonna send you a
copy of um my new book on your past
change your future and it will walk you
through the grieving process a whole
chapter on grief and what do i do next
i also think it's in this situation i
know there's more to this story and man
i'd love to unpack it if we had time
i think it's worth saying hey when
you're ready
breakfast is on me
and i'll meet you at any ihop or denny's
in the area we'll meet at 10 o'clock in
the morning on saturday it's on me when
you're ready i'd love to talk
and
you can send that in a handwritten
letter not a text message a handwritten
letter to say hey i'd love to talk with
you i miss you and
i know you're hurting but one day when
you're ready i'll be ready too
so sorry i wish i had some big
fancy dust i could sprinkle over this
one but this one's gonna hurt for a
while i'm proud of you for sticking to
your boundaries proud of him for being
honest with you proud of everybody in
this situation and
yuck
still hurts at the end we'll be right
back
hey delony here one of the things i love
about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible and each person's situation
is unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if i do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as i'd love to i can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
i wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what i would say if you
and i were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book i will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the new roads of a well life
moving forward go to johndaloni.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at johndaloni.com
all right as we wrap up today's show it
is a heavy show
this is heavy right
damn
it's my my favorite songs ever and by
favorite i mean i've never even heard of
this person ever
um
i've never heard this song in my life
but i'm going with it's one of my
favorites and it's by the great
marshmallow
and demi lovato
and the song
i hope those people are cool the song is
called i'm uh
okay not to be okay and it goes like
this
feeling like a drop in the ocean but
don't nobody notice maybe it's all just
in your head
feeling like you're trapped in your own
skin and now your body's frozen broken
down you've got nothing left when you're
high on emotion and you're losing your
focus and you feel too exhausted to pray
don't get lost in the moment or give up
when you're closest all you need is
somebody to say
it's okay not to be okay
when you're down and you feel ashamed
it's okay
not to be okay all right i take that
back that's a good tune man well done
everybody hey we'll see you soon on the
dr john delaney show
coming up on the next episode he had an
affair about 10 years ago and i told him
if he ever ever cheated on me again i
would leave him for good and
recently he got fired for sexual
harassment at his job can i ever trust
him again forgiveness is for you it's
not for him forgiveness is you holding
this brick that he placed in your hands
a brick of infidelity a brick of lack of
trust a brick of dishonesty
and forgiveness is you setting that down
and saying i'm not carrying your stuff
anymore okay so i got married in
november this is my second marriage okay
um we don't live together why don't you
all live together because the housing
market is still high here we're just
kind of sitting and waiting i guess
you'll get together for weekend hookups
or whatever but like this isn't a
marriage